I hope you
[Music]
I hope you enjoy the film some of you
may have seen it maybe one or two of you
television on Cosby mysteries which
really was a mystery nobody could find
it that is nobody with Nielsen box the
the families that you saw three bring it
down instead three different economic
levels mother and father musician doctor
brother mother and father God we won't
go into why they're not there but the
older brother bringing up his young
sibling and then the single parent
working as a domestic
the question for us I think is with the
killings and the way we're looking at
our neighborhoods and how people are
killing the selling of dangerous things
and how it's being sold and the lack of
respect for the age of the person it's
being sold to the disappointing discing
of education
the disappointing choices that we use
when we vote local people into office
the seeming lack of respect for the
elders the seeming lack of respect for
the younger people
the lack of respect for self and some
people and the hope that a newborn child
coming out of your body is going to
brighten your life forever and make you
feel better about yourself when in fact
you don't respect yourself in the first
place this is not everybody I'm talking
about some people some people here we
are at Howard University I don't know
how many of you are students here but
how many of you really and truly are
professional see students
just enough to get by just enough to get
by and so on another level you were not
much better than the people who are just
trying to get by who haven't gone to
college and that's what I want to ask
that we have to discuss at some point
when you have free time with each other
the question is are some people dead if
it is that you are willing to take
prison as opposed to a life outside with
certainly more freedom outside then
being incarcerated are you dead if you
say that your home is not as good as a
prison cell but you have the freedom
that they don't have in prison are you
dead
if your excuse is or if you know someone
whose excuse for selling crack and being
responsible for maybe a hundred deaths a
hundred robberies a hundred battered
women and you say this is so you can put
your mother in a better home are you
dead
if you see and you notice kids who don't
want to hang and they're studying and
you decide to get a group together pull
them over and beat them up or make them
join your group that isn't studying and
you have the nerve to use a phrase like
you're acting white are you dead
some people don't seem to understand the
lock that they've put on themselves you
live in the projects and you hear
somebody say I'm getting out of here and
you get mad at dumb [ __ ] once what's
wrong with the project's
there's a lot that you have to think
about the projects were never built for
generations of families the same last
name to take the apartment one out for
the other if the projects is set so that
while you're not doing well momentarily
people come and the biggest thing is the
pride my great grandparents were
immigrants and they came and my father
to the didn't grandfather and work and
week and I'm the first to graduate from
college that I'm the doctor and so forth
and so on yet there are people in the
projects I have generations still there
anybody here from Chicago
No Chicago went up to boys not even dry
yet from coming out of the mother threw
another one off the building no just
threw him right off are they dead when
we can have our young coming out and
deciding that they're already dead at
age nine ten thirteen the young boys
throwing another one off the 12th floor
because he wouldn't do something they
said through them all they don't have to
see it in a movie they just went through
mom when ten-year-old girls decide that
they want to practice sex so they can
have a baby at 12 but he did
you have to discuss this because it
isn't going to be solved by shaking a
finger at somebody we've been shaking
fingers too long dr. King said I have a
dream it's time for for us to wake up
time to wake up I have a dream that's
wonderful
he gave you that message what did you do
with it
when young girls still listen to snort
hockey park love whoever it is
he's calling you [ __ ] and hoes and
said the only reason why you because you
want to free did anything and used up in
the room playing the music and people
say listen do you know what he said
- yeah but it's got a good beat are you
dead are you dead
what do you mean he doesn't mean any
harm
couldn't have you bought the album
you're worse than he is
[Applause]
and we're gonna stop blaming people
going to stop blaming other people the
buck stops in the discussion to go to
Howard University old money was student
loan do you have a intention paying it
back
[Applause]
so you're making it tougher for the next
african-americans to come to Howard
are you dead are you dead
are you dead that you're leaving nothing
for your descendants are you dead ask
some of the graduates who've never sent
a penny to Howard University
[Applause]
send them a note and thank them for
nothing and then ask them if they'd like
to change their minds asking if they did
you mean to tell me you can't afford $5
you can sit up on a certain afternoon
buy a shot of scotch I bet you bet you
can get a pack of cigarettes give up
something so we got to find out if some
of these people are really dead because
the way they're acting they've given up
on themselves already sometimes we have
to look at the elders of the village and
ask them if they're dead the university
presidents we have to ask the Board of
Trustees are they dead
[Applause]
we have to ask the Board of Trustees why
to bring in certain people supposed to
be educating Americans I'd live alone at
any point at any time when we had as
african-americans advanced so far that
we could steal from each other
first of all we don't have that much so
it is notice right away
secondly you didn't get that much one
over a cup of cold and take two million
dollars and then go to a nice prison
nice prison not the ones that you know
they lock up rapists and stuff in steal
two million dollars it's n you play golf
people people put your IQ and the paper
keep asking the same question now how
many of you go sir appear at from time
to time listen to Farrakhan and you
cheer from sit down right on right on
and and go out and do nothing do nothing
Jesse Jackson comes from Berlin right
dog thing is over you go outside do
nothing don't even talk about it you
know boom ba bad because practicing
walking
and some some people that did summer did
listen to a politician tell you that it
was somebody else's fault somebody
else's fault I don't know how to smoke
crack the beautiful woman came up to me
and said you can make love to me if you
smoke crack I said well where is it
[Applause]
[Applause]
sits in the bathroom in fact that you
have to put it all together and I'll get
myself ready for you be a long time
before I come out of that bathroom
I don't know what to do with it I don't
know where to put it
I'm talking about to crack
[Applause]
so I am wondering how you can be set up
[Applause]
but yet the voters all they push and
talk about some some mythical white
people mythical white people set me up
mythical mythical white people came in
the projects
[Music]
mythical mystical white people in
America welding the problem is the dead
people are waiting to be given something
and when the time comes and they get it
they're not gonna be ready to deliver
anyway so what would happen is well man
I think I gave here they set me up to
fail white people man
what are you talking about why the cat
came by and gave us a million dollars to
run the thing but you know we really
just went down here with it well what
happened what he didn't they didn't show
us how to spend it
wait a minute they gave you a million
dollars and they had to show you how to
spend it what you doing asking for it do
you understand what I'm telling you
don't start a business and start with
the building looking like you've been in
business a hundred years if you start a
business in your basement when the time
is right you moved to the first floor of
your house
but if you want an excuse well I'll have
a computer on I have a building I don't
have cause many cars go yeah read any
success story any business person man or
woman they didn't start with a
four-story marbled building with rugs
they had linoleum floors and the parents
looked at him and said are you crazy
burning a hole in my linoleum rug John
Johnson sold his mother's furniture with
her permission by the way got $500 to
start evany magazine now what are you
gonna do about that
what's your Excuse once you choose well
it's already established so I mean he's
uh that was then this is now
little hug yes you can go down the hall
I mean I just need a loan four million
dollars that I get you don't know how to
run a magazine would a million dollars
yet start with your low end you people
want to make movies first thing you
start writing people they don't want
real people with real black people kind
that go out frightened white people at
the mall
your movies have no tenderness they
don't even have foreplay
foreplay they'd only met phone you know
what the foreplay is in most of these
movie John stop stop come on now that's
foreplay
I showed this to you because there's no
cursing in that there's certainly nobody
jumping on bone jumping there are people
trying to figure out what went wrong
people who care and people who forgive
and there's a policeman in this who said
I want the boy to say it because if he
doesn't he never will be worth anything
we're going to catch him we know we
haven't but I want him to say it there's
a touching and a feeling and a caring
and a respect in this movie
yeah not old people but young people and
I didn't try to make it real because
what is real and what is but and how
many different tiers of black happen you
all go to college come from Chicago come
from Detroit come from Philly come from
Peoria come from California
we reach advantage for California all
over Seattle Washington come here bad
people come from all over the place
there's no contest I'm blacker than you
okay if you plug into me then what does
that mean how do you get to be blacker
than me this real black man there is
real black woman all right what do they
look like how do they walk how do they
talk real black
I know real black really
you'll get fooled because some people
have more patience than others but we'll
still do the same amount of damage if
you make am angry some people will fly
off the handle very quickly and I've
seen people who never raise their voice
and teeth separated about a quarter of
an inch
and they never move the Lipset Singh
but the I said if you do that again
you're gonna be in trouble I was born
1937
1937
we were told constantly where to sit
where to stand where to go and we don't
want you in some places in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania and I was constantly
cheering on people like Joe Lewis
because it meant somebody won something
I cheered Jesse Owens and saw him win on
film and every time I I was just I
always hoped he would win because I
didn't know what was gonna happen is the
same film over and over but I just I
wasn't sure to film because it's fantasy
it's a fantasy
when you are a child growing up the
United States of America and constantly
being told no that's not right you can't
make it there even to the point where
heroes I wasn't sure them heroes could
have embarrassed me marian anderson's
going to sing in front of the statue of
Abraham Lincoln and I said oh god please
don't let it hit a bad note I'll be so
embarrassed Who am I to be embarrassed
but I had that feeling and it went all
over the nation why because they said
she couldn't say lips too
thick-skinned too dark is what they mean
nothing to do with lips and all of you
out there have to understand that it's
still the same and I'm saying you have
better today
see how would university to make those
of you who went to high schools
integrated not integrated you come here
and Howard University represents and can
represent upon your enthusiasm if you're
not dead represents your country follow
me now Chinese people have China they
study they come here they take the SATs
they go wherever they want to go
Princeton Berkeley so Corbin soil not
all of them not all of them people come
from Italy people come from England
Britain Sweden whatever they have
countries we live in the United States
of America which has stipulations for us
some we can get through because of a
right person without guilt said yeah a
man stop this come on
but Howard University is your country
this is where you come to get to feel
that all of the things the marian
anderson's and Ken she and Ken Jesse and
Ken Joe Lewis and Ken Michael Jordan but
we don't we don't see our Astra
yet we don't see our brain surgeons we
don't see the surgeons that separated
Siamese twins very fuzzy but it's here
with your professors then you begin to
see people who are extremely bright
knowledgeable have it together and care
about you now you want to be a
professional C student and leave this
country and go out there and embarrass
Mary lens I want you to write a letter
to your professors especially the ones
that you cut and shortchange tell them
you're sorry and begin to pick up the
pieces this is your country this is
where you learn that you are tough this
is where you learn when you walk down
that aisle and your parents are sitting
up there and they got about 25 cents
left
these are the graduations where the
little children run around on that day
just running up and down the aisles me
this is where grandma with or without a
walker comes because Jesus has blessed
her and you want to come here and be a
professional C student wear your dime so
are you dead
I don't care if you don't know what you
want to be but please don't use an
excuse of well you know people make a
decision and then they have to turn
around them and can't be whatever I
learned about it man
just work hard everything you get you
think of course you say I want to know
this is your country and the only way
you're going to build strength is right
here because when you come out of here
you'll go to some graduate school
somewhere and they're gonna look at you
and say where are you from from Howard
so yeah that's the place where they
laughed and cheered when OJ Simpson was
free that's you only claim the fame huh
nobody came up masked you why you
cheered did they they just said you
cheered
that's old style you know they're not
going to ask because they're afraid
they'll get a decent answer
this United States of America is about
every thing whether it's hidden or out
there supposedly college graduates are
supposed to be supposedly the strengths
of our country
if that's so then why do the drug dealer
stand out
why do pregnant teenagers stand out why
is a rundown neighborhood black that if
you live in the suburbs you are not
black if you know a dessert spoon from a
teaspoon you are not black and if you
don't if you don't eat chitlins or never
tasted them
so people now in terms of pride they
named their their children these Muslim
African names the Kadeen Rashid and I
see him on the six o'clock news going
into the police station handcuffs stab
somebody in the back over 25 cent chain
they forgot the name didn't they didn't
they forget what the name was supposed
to me I mean if you name somebody
something of the strength and the power
of God you would think that the person
would say that's who I am and the mother
would explain it
and then the person would adhere to it
and carry it on and don't we have enough
days where people can recognize their
blackness their american-ness because
this is America no sense of run away
from it you want a major in black
English not checked
not till you get a black business not
till you get a not till you get a black
airport
when a black landing tower and you can
say no you're gonna have to speak black
English coming in here
[Applause]
are you yeah this fight is about
progress and you're never gonna progress
if you are male unless you recognize the
female not the wave the Bible wrote
about the female but the way the female
ought to be treated now I'm sorry to say
that many females have to treat the
female the way the female and you have
to have respect and you have to pass it
on to your siblings I'm asking you to go
out into the community if you can if you
are willing find as many dead people as
you can try and bring them back to life
because you really don't need somebody
to say one thing and then pull back on
another and you know the people I'm
talking about and blame everybody can't
blame everybody man yes a great deal of
this is self-inflicted but it certainly
is not the end can't be telling me this
is it in the 30s people love cars pull
up what a car woman jump right in you
know guy with the bike can't make out
nothing has changed and mysteriously
certain young ladies who wouldn't let
anybody touch him had to go down south
for the
or the winter
and when they came back their mother had
had a baby
oh yes that's the way it used to be yeah
you get she get pregnant they send it
down south and she's down south she went
north just for vacation a couple of
months then she came back her mother had
a baby today it's different they just
have them just have him three four oh I
remember how embarrassed a woman made me
feel I was I was a lifeguard in 1963 and
then the lady girl really had had two
one two and one was in ER and she called
a boy who I was the lifeguard public
apology she got in those days they
didn't have the Muslim names yet is it
Richard and Richard Ritchie came out and
he went in an end and whole cigarette
out gave her singer won the joint
cigarette she wanted a cigarette Richard
is the father of one of the children one
good cigarette from him then I went over
to and I said these are these your
children I'm going to Temple University
at the time saying I'm ready to make a
change in the world I want to talk to
this young lady these your children this
because I was bullying right in that
area right in that drumming 12 and all
of that numb down there I'm now that
lifeguard in the pool that I used to go
into as a kid you know I might stuff in
command of my neighborhood and I said
these if these is your children you had
these children in you have oh she says
so I said yeah but you got you have to
you don't have a job you'd leave these
boys on she says so and she just kept it
up every time I said some cheese's so
nothing I could do she just sold me
right on into embarrassment I'm talking
about today talking about today and I
don't want you to be afraid don't be
afraid you can't be afraid last time you
all demonstrated about anything
1988 your predecessors and I'm saying
it's time for you to demonstrate a game
but now wait a minute
you see how ready you are they ready
they ready I'm saying demonstrate about
yourselves and are you dead look at who
you are
take that easy taste out of your mouth
because American is a very bitter place
for dead people I'm saying you don't
need people to come up here and put
vanilla and polish over half truths so
that you can walk out and do nothing I'm
charging you nothing for today's thing
you don't have to put anything in a
bucket I'm saying to you you know when
you're wrong and you know who you own
and you know who owns you
and you know what ought to be important
you got grandma coming to graduation
ask her about foolishness
ask your grandmother what she would like
to see smell a perfume when you talk to
her on graduation day look at how clear
her glasses are so she could see you
look at granddad people spent pension
money to come to your graduation an
african-american colleges all over the
United States of America these
graduations gone people dressed in
orange and red colors that they dead and
you don't see them another graduation
fathers would suits on did this [ __ ]
done your like this and the only time
they win is a funeral or graduation
fathers and I don't care if you don't
have a father if you haven't seen one so
what get on with your life and if you
don't have a mullet so what get on with
it if your mother's a drunkard if your
fathers are junkie get on with your life
cuz it's about you
you are polluting if you're going to sit
around and whine and talk about who did
what and why you couldn't this is your
country got a problem at Howard see
somebody and if they won't see you
there's your revolution
you come out of here with a c' average
then you're big and white people to
affirm the action now why at this point
you want to go around begging white
people when you don't know them and
you're going to be and what's more
embarrassing you're embarrassing the
person behind you because you're not
qualified with your professional see
self-sustainable and you as a brother or
sister with an a-average then you're
wasting their time while you arguing
about your c-average self now is that
black or what now which one of the
people in line is black because the one
with the A's these are studying the East
acting white really you mean the lazy C
student is it's real black person is
that what you're saying when the
Huxtables were on television there's so
many people are waiting so many people
so many people I heard it until I just I
mean it was just ridiculous institution
well you know that's not a real black
family is that so I said well you know
you need to get out more often
[Applause]
and even even if it wasn't is anybody
have a problem with seeing the future
does anybody have a problem with seeing
a family say to their children you will
do this because I know more than you and
this is what you will do and this is
what you won't get away with anybody
have a problem with parenting for a
change it's well they really do go to
the ball off cliff said you can't go to
the mall you have to go to the books
cliff huxtable made a mistake when he
didn't know that Theo was dyslexic
check it out sometimes when you watching
those shows that was the beautiful part
of that series because once they found
out that he really wasn't lying about he
had tried he had studied but he still
got a B then the family judge said well
there's got to be something wrong
because he he's not that good at lying
that concretely and so they found out he
was dyslexic and they cheered why
because something was wrong with the boy
just wasn't crazy just that in lost his
mind there was something wrong and they
began to work at it and he graduated
from NYU Lux will spend $100,000 on his
graduation cliff so proud go to
graduation to see his son go up and get
a diploma but it NYU they don't do that
they say alright everybody was in this
stand-up in the manway eclipses hell I
didn't have to pay that much money cuz
it is bought him a cap and gown and said
I'm not this is stand-up and that's it
we don't do that yet it Howard do we huh
you go up somewhere so grandma and
granddad can see you so your siblings
look dumb brothers and sisters
getting away with murder I'm telling you
you got to realize that the speakers
coming it can't make it easy for you
you've got to study you've got to pay
the price
and take the pain and the time to
realize that even though it feels good
generally these things have to do with
somebody making money from you the Snoop
Dogg ate poop calling you a [ __ ] in the
home and you gonna buy the record and
dance cuz he's got a good beat and then
you're gonna confess to people well do
you know it really doesn't mean and if
you know what I know right if you did
buy it would you listen to there's too
many things that are just obvious and
you gotta wake up not you but you the
people who are dead that's what's sad I
don't think you you've really realized
how beautiful you can be you don't need
people to tell you that Jews are no good
you don't need somebody to tell you that
so you can stand up what are you gonna
do with it in the first place we just go
huh get them off the campus for what you
can't get them off the counters just
don't even worry about it that's what
I'm saying you don't have to remove but
why cheers somebody like that it's not
true it's not true because you've got to
go through the same kind of
decision-making that you're asking
people to do about you are you there
you don't you think of mine if you want
people to judge you as an individual you
want to get job this is no black people
he's awaiting a minute man you'd say we
all we all make too much noise we all do
that aren't you saying to people don't
judge me like that you're stereotyping
me I'm not correct
I'm saying to you if you know Jewish
Jewish Polish Jewish Russian Jewish
German and all of them are like that
then you're the first person that I've
ever met that had tremendous bad luck
you know Irish people that all Irish
people are like that but if you continue
to take the easy way out and all you're
gonna do is pout you see a white person
roll your eyes you go up you listen to
this speaker tell you that the people of
permanent-magnet heart and apartment
when the bridge and you were read and
then you go outside you don't own the
airport you don't own a department store
[Applause]
you gotta get a pride and yourselves
you've got to communicate with each
other you got to get rid of this easy
thing and set up and go to these movies
and and people are banging and throwing
women off and you're playing top dollar
to Hollywood movies that say this is all
you like but if you stop going to these
movies Jesse Jackson doesn't have to go
to Hollywood and have black actresses
make a fool of him on TV
but you had to expect a remark like that
to come from that person because didn't
they have a boyfriend that put on
blackface
[Applause]
now let's get back to you now I'm
telling you that most the most difficult
thing for your young lives is to begin
to disassociate this associate yourself
from stereotyping especially when you
don't want anybody doing it about you
first of all you're young you don't have
any power so how you gonna get rid of
somebody secondly you're young and you
owe everybody so who's gonna pay
attention to you
thirdly you're young and you're confused
you don't know how to do anything you
just wish upon graduation somebody will
just take you and stay come here let me
hide you for a couple of months until
all the expectations were all away
it's so much BS to be sold I just don't
want you I don't want to see your faces
cheering on somebody and they're just
givin you a half a piece of brand half a
piece of bread I know you're hungry for
truth and I know you're hungry for
honesty and I know you're especially
hungry for somebody somewhere to say
unfair but in the meantime we all have
to live like that as well your life will
not be any easier for you to follow
speakers who will throw up things and
you have somebody to blame because what
you do then is very dangerous you begin
to both people in the office who are
like that too and there you still sit
somewhere close to the projects are you
dead the youth coming behind you I think
that for the young men in terms of
dealing with the women
I don't understand how you can have a
mother who raised you and you understand
women
bless your mother there's something you
want from this other woman not a comfort
zone or stop I think that as animals
we're all a man I did my share and and
took somebody else's share Oh at night
and told lies and beg but I'm telling
you as an elder of the village don't be
afraid to get yourself together
women trick yes they do human beings
won't be looking at your wallet was she
looking over your shoulder that ago that
she really likes yeah it can do that
because you're looking between the legs
while you looking over your shoulder as
the one you might want to marry
[Applause]
but it's a fun game as long as you don't
do any damage you want to hear the music
you want to do the dance you have to pay
the piper it's a very costly dance I
want to end all of this by saying to
each and every one of you that the film
and what I've said here this afternoon
what you know is very difficult to live
the way I've asked you to because it
means that you can only blame the people
who are really responsible and sometimes
that's you and it's hard to swallow
I want to thank everybody for the time
especially the little children who
thought they were going to get some free
jell-o pudding I want to tell you all so
that you all can become our heroes very
important and I mean celebrities we
would love to look out and just be proud
so thank you all very very much good
afternoon
on behalf of the student body we like
the thing with the Cosby a game for
giving us this time for coming out and
we're very very appreciative so let's
give them one more round
[Applause]
there were some missing some young so
weird those youngsters no they were
sitting right now